(Aplausos)
La dualidad es la capacidad de mantener ambas cosas.
Pero la pregunta es: ¿Podemos poseer nuestra dualidad?
¿Podemos tener el coraje de mantener ambas cosas?
Yo trabajé en un restaurante de la ciudad.
Me hice muy amiga de una camarera.
Yo era la maître y tuvimos una gran relación,
nos lo pasamos muy bien juntas.
Su español era genial
porque ella era de México.
(Risas)
Eso era también en sentido inverso.
Su inglés era limitado, pero significativamente mejor que mi español.
Pero estábamos unidas por nuestras similitudes,
no separadas por nuestras diferencias.
Y estábamos cerca, a pesar ser de mundos muy diferentes.
Ella era de México,
dejó a su familia para poder venir aquí
y darles una mejor vida.
Ella era una católica devota conservadora,
creyente en los valores tradicionales de la familia,
funciones estereotipadas de hombres y mujeres,
y yo era, pues yo.
(Risas)
Lo que nos unía era cuando me preguntaba por mi novia,
o cuando compartía fotos de su familia.
Eran las cosas que nos unían.
Un día estábamos en la parte de atrás,
engullendo tan rápido como podíamos, alrededor de una pequeña mesa,
durante una pausa muy rara,
y vino un chico nuevo de la cocina,
resultó ser su primo,
y se sentó con toda la osadía y el machismo
que sus 20 años podían contener en su cuerpo.
(Risas)
Y le dijo: [en español] "¿Ash tiene novio?"
Y ella dijo: [en español] "No, tiene novia".
Y él dijo: [en español] "¡¿Una novia?!"
Y ella dejó el tenedor, y le clavó los ojos,
y dijo: [en español] "Sí, una novia. Eso es todo".
Y su sonrisa de suficiencia cambió rápidamente a una de respeto materno,
tomó su plato, se marchó, volvió a trabajar.
Ella nunca hizo contacto visual conmigo.
Ella se fue, hizo lo mismo...
fueron 10 seg. de conversación, con poca interacción.
Y en el papel, ella tenía mucho más en común con él:
lengua, cultura, historia, familia y su comunidad era su tabla de salvación aquí,
pero su brújula moral triunfó sobre todo eso.
Y un poco más tarde, bromeaban en la cocina en español,
sobre algo que no tenía nada que ver conmigo,
y "eso" es la dualidad.
No tenía que elegir entre una postura sobre la homosexualidad y su herencia.
Ella no tenía que elegir entre su familia y nuestra amistad.
Ni entre Jesús o Ash.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Su moral individual estaba tan fuertemente arraigada
que tuvo el coraje de mantener ambas cosas.
Nuestra integridad moral es nuestra responsabilidad
y debemos estar preparados para defenderla, incluso si no es conveniente.
Eso es lo que significa ser aliado, y si van a ser un aliado,
tienen que ser un aliado activo:
Hagan preguntas, actúen al escuchar algo inapropiado,
realmente participen.
Yo tenía una amiga de la familia que por años llamó a mi novia mi "amante".
¿En serio? ¿Amante?
Así excesivamente sexual,
como los porno gay de los 70.
(Risas)
Pero ella lo intentó y me preguntó.
podría haberla llamado mi "amiga",
o "amiga", o mi "amiga especial"
(Risas)
o peor aún, no haber preguntado nada.
Créanme, preferimos que se nos pregunte.
Yo preferiría que la llamara mi amante a que no dijera nada en absoluto.
La gente a menudo me dice: "Ash, no me importa.
No veo la raza ni la religión ni la sexualidad.
No me importa. Yo no lo veo".
Pero creo que lo contrario de homofobia, racismo y xenofobia no es amor,
es apatía.
Si no ven mi homosexualidad, entonces no me ven.
Si no les importa con quien me acuesto,
entonces no se pueden imaginar lo que se siente
cuando camino por la calle tarde en la noche, sosteniendo su mano,
y acercarse a un grupo de personas y tener que tomar la decisión
de si debo aferrarme a ella o si debo soltarla
cuando lo único que quiero hacer es apretarla con más fuerza.
Y la pequeña victoria que siento
cuando lo hago y no tengo que soltarla.
Y la cobardía increíble y decepción que siento cuando la suelto.
Si no ven esta lucha
única en mi experiencia humana por ser gay, entonces no me ven.
Si Uds. van a ser aliados, necesito que me vean.
Como personas, como aliados, como seres humanos,
debemos poder mantener ambas cosas:
tanto lo bueno como lo malo,
lo fácil y lo difícil.
No se aprende a sostener dos cosas desde la tibieza,
se aprende desde la firmeza.
¿Y si la dualidad es solo el primer paso?
¿Qué pasa si a través de la compasión, la empatía y la interacción humana
podemos aprender a sostener 2 cosas?
Y si podemos sostener 2 cosas, podemos sostener 4,
y si podemos sostener 4, podemos sostener 8,
y si podemos sostener 8, podemos sostener cientos.
Somos individuos complejos,
remolinos de contradicción.
Todos Uds. sostienen muchas cosas en este momento.
¿Qué se puede hacer para mantener un poco más?
Así que, volviendo a Toledo, Ohio.
Estoy en el frente de la fila,
mi sobrina en mis hombros, la empleada agotada me llama papá.
¿Alguna vez les han acreditado con el género equivocado?
Ni siquiera eso.
¿Alguna vez les han tildado de algo que no son?
Esto es lo que yo siento ante eso:
Al instante soy una tormenta interna de emociones enfrentadas.
Rompo a sudar en una combinación de rabia y humillación,
siento cómo toda la tienda me está mirando,
y al mismo tiempo me siento invisible.
Quiero explotar en una diatriba de furia,
y quiero esconderme debajo de una roca.
Y encima de todo eso, con la frustración por usar
una ajustada camiseta púrpura
donde toda esta tienda puede verme las tetas,
para asegurarme de que esto mismo no debe suceder.
(Risas)
Pero, a pesar de mis mejores esfuerzos para que me vean con el género que soy,
todavía sucede.
Y espero con cada kg de mi cuerpo que nadie lo oyera,
ni mi hermana, ni mi novia, y mucho menos mi sobrina.
Estoy acostumbrada a esta herida familiar,
pero haré lo que tengo que hacer para proteger a la gente que quiero.
Pero luego bajé a mi sobrina de los hombros,
y ella corrió hacia Elsa y Anna
por lo que había esperado tanto tiempo,
y todo eso se me pasa.
Lo único que importa es la sonrisa en su rostro.
Y cuando faltaban 30 seg. de las dos horas y media de espera
recogimos nuestras cosas e intercambié de nuevo una mirada con la empleada;
y ella me dio una sonrisa de disculpa y murmuró:
"¡Lo siento!"
(Risas)
Y su humanidad, su voluntad de admitir su error me desarmó inmediatamente,
entonces yo: "Está bien, pasa, pero gracias".
Y me doy cuenta en ese momento
de que ya no tengo que ser
o una tía o una militante, que pueden ser ambas a la vez.
Puedo vivir en la dualidad, y puedo ser dos cosas.
Y si puedo ser dos cosas en ese medio,
y puedo sostener tantas cosas más.
Cuando mi novia y mi sobrina se van de la mano por la puerta delantera,
me dirijo a mi hermana y le digo: "¿Valió la pena?"
Y ella dijo: "¿Estás bromeando?
¿Has visto la expresión de su cara? ¡Fue el mejor día de su vida! "
(Risas)
"Valió la pena las dos horas y media en el calor,
valió la pena el libro caro del que ya teníamos una copia".
(Risas)
"Incluso valió la pena que te llamaran papá".
Y por primera vez en mi vida, así fue.
Gracias, Boulder. Que tengan una buena noche.
(Aplausos)